C'est un honneur pour moi ce matin de vous apporter la parole de Dieu.
C'est merveilleux de voir l'église de David et les brebis de son troupeau.
C'est une joie pour moi de collaborer avec mon ami Hansworth Jonas qui est avec nous aujourd'hui.
Je prie au Seigneur pour que vous puissiez être fidèles au Seigneur et à sa vérité.
Et que le prédicatif qui se passe ici dans cette salle chaque semaine soit utilisé pour la glorie de Dieu, pour la salvation des vêtements et pour la maturation des saints.
Et je prie que les prédications fidèles qui ont eu lieu de façon hebdomadaire ici puissent contribuer à la gloire de Dieu, à la sanctification des croyants et au salut des perdus.
Au 16ème siècle, Dieu a amené la réforme en France.
Et Calvin lui a envoyé à lui-même plusieurs missionnaires en France qui ont partagé l'évangile sous la persécution au prix même de leur sang.
Et que Dieu puisse amener le réveil à nouveau en France.
Et que cela puisse partir, jaillir même de cette église.
Et de votre coeur.
Et que cela puisse s'étendre partout en France.
Et que la France puisse être à nouveau connue comme étant un pays biblique qui sert le Seigneur.
Et que la France puisse être à nouveau réellement bénie.
Et ce matin, j'aimerais regarder à ce que les bénédictions sont réellement.
Et même, je voudrais vous parler des bénédictions contagieuses.
Comme on le voit dans la vie de Jacob.
In that mysterious encounter Jacob had with the angel of the covenant.
Avec cette rencontre mystérieuse que Jacob a eue avec cet ange de l'Alliance.
As he wrestled with him.
Alors qu'il a combattu avec lui.
Until the breaking of the day.
Jusqu'au lever du jour.
So turn with me please to Genesis chapter 32.
Ouvrez donc la Bible avec moi dans le chapitre 32 du livre de Genèse.
Et nous allons lire du verset 22 jusqu'au verset 32.
Genèse 32 verset 22.
Il se leva la même nuit.
Prit ses deux femmes, ses deux servantes et ses onze enfants.
Et passa le biais de Jacob.
Il les prit.
Leur fit passer le torrent.
Et le fit passer à tout ce qui lui appartenait.
Jacob demeura seul.
Alors un homme lutta avec lui.
Jusqu'au lever de l'aurore.
Voyant qu'il ne pouvait le vaincre.
Cet homme le frappa à l'emboiture de la hanche.
Et l'emboiture de la hanche de Jacob se démit pendant qu'il luttait avec lui.
Il dit.
Laisse-moi aller.
Car l'aurore se lève.
Et Jacob répondit.
Je ne te laisserai point aller que tu ne m'aies béni.
Il lui dit.
Quel est ton nom ?
Et il répondit.
Jacob.
Il dit encore.
Ton nom ne sera plus Jacob.
Mais tu seras appelé Israël.
Car tu as lutté avec Dieu et avec des hommes.
Et tu as été vainqueur.
Jacob l'interrogea.
Fais-moi je te prie connaître ton nom.
Il répondit.
Pourquoi demandes-tu mon nom ?
Et il le bénit là.
Jacob appela son lieu du nom de Péniel.
Car dit-il.
J'ai vu Dieu face à face.
Et mon âme a été sauvée.
Le soleil se levait.
Lorsqu'il passa Péniel.
Jacob boitait de la hanche.
C'est pourquoi jusqu'à ce jour.
Les enfants d'Israël ne mangent point le tendon.
Qui est à l'emboiture de la hanche.
Car Dieu frappa Jacob à l'emboiture de la hanche.
Au tendon.
Jacob n'était pas une personne très sympathique.
Son nom même veut dire le trompeur.
Celui qui trompe.
Le dupeur.
In his youth.
He deceived his brother Esau.
Et dans sa jeunesse.
Il a trompé son frère Esaü.
And tried to steal from him.
The rights of the first born son.
En essayant de lui voler son droit d'aînesse.
And then later on.
Jacob deceived his blind father.
Et plus tard.
Jacob a trompé son père.
Qui devenait aveugle.
To get Esau's blessing.
Pour avoir les bénédictions d'Esaü.
And even use the name of God.
To get it.
And he used the name of God.
In the holiest of things.
The most saint of things.
Jacob lied.
Jacob a menti.
Jacob deceived.
Jacob a trompé.
And Jacob's craftiness.
Backfired on him.
And Jacob.
Pardon.
The perfect.
He was forced to leave his parents.
Without friends.
Without possessions.
Except for a staff in his hand.
And a cruise of oil.
He could scarcely have been more poor.
than in this condition.
He crossed over the Jordan.
As he left the land of promise.
And he traversed the Jordan.
Versed the land of promise.
Behind him.
He left a cursing brother.
And weeping parents.
And he left a cursing brother.
And a cursing brother.
Everything seemed hopeless.
And all seemed hopeless.
Jacob was a homeless man.
He was miserable.
What future did he have?
But astonishingly.
The Lord came and visited Jacob.
Amazing grace.
What a wonderful grace.
At Bethel.
Jacob stops for the night.
Jacob was a homeless man.
And God visits him.
And God visits Jacob.
And assures him.
That as his faithful.
Covenant keeping God.
He would one day.
Bring Jacob back.
To the land of promise.
And he would take care of him.
And bless him.
And after Jacob travels.
A long way.
And after Jacob.
Amazingly.
God leads him.
To his own mother's family.
Jacob found a home.
He found a job.
He found a woman to love.
And the Lord blessed his work.
Even though his uncle Laban tried to change his wages.
Ten times.
Deceiving Jacob.
The way Jacob had deceived Esau and his dad.
En trompant Jacob.
Comme Jacob avait lui-même trompé son frère et son père.
Jacob continued to prosper.
Et bien Jacob continua à prospérer.
And then after serving his uncle for 20 years.
Et après avoir servi son uncle pendant 20 ans.
God told Jacob to go back to the promised land.
Dieu dit à Jacob.
Retour maintenant au pays promis.
And Jacob went back rich in possessions.
Et Jacob revient alors rich de possessions.
Rich in family.
Rich de famille.
70 souls.
Avec 70 âmes.
So God had pursued Jacob in all his wanderings.
And blessed him.
Donc Dieu a accompagné Jacob dans tous ses égarements.
Et l'a béni abondamment.
So Jacob packs everything up and leaves.
Donc Jacob a pris ses affaires et parti.
But when Laban heard about it.
Mais quand Laban a entendu cela.
He pursued it.
Il a commencé à le poursuivre.
And he overtook him at Mount Gilead.
Et il l'a attrapé à Gilead.
But there God wonderfully revealed himself to Jacob again.
And there God told Jacob.
Angels reassured Jacob.
That God would protect him against Laban.
Who was coming at him from one direction.
And the angels assured Jacob.
That God told Jacob that he was coming at him from one direction.
And he saw his brother.
Who he heard was coming at him from the other direction.
With a militia of 400 men.
Supposedly to take revenge on Jacob.
Certainement pour prendre sa revanche envers Jacob.
Even after all those years.
Même après toutes ces années.
What a position to be in.
Quelle position que celle de Jacob.
Laban pressing.
Esau pressing.
Laban d'un côté qui le presse.
Et de l'autre côté Esaü son frère.
Where could Jacob go?
Où est-ce que Jacob pouvait alors aller?
Well Jacob.
Is driven to his knees in prayer.
Alors Jacob est amené à la prière sur ses genoux.
In verses 9 through 12 of this chapter.
Du verset 9 à 12 dans ce même chapitre.
He cries out to God.
Il crie à Dieu.
A gracious God.
Un Dieu gracieux.
There's nothing of Jacob in this prayer.
He's had to give up on himself.
Il abandonne.
Il s'abandonne lui-même.
But he pleads on God's covenant.
Mais il plaide au Dieu de l'alliance.
He pleads on God's command.
Il plaide au commandement de Dieu.
Il plaide aux promesses de Dieu.
Il plaide aux miséricordes de Dieu.
Il plaide aux délivrances de Dieu.
Il plaide la délivrance de Dieu.
Et il plaide la fidélité.
C'est vraiment une prière orientée sur Dieu exclusivement.
Et puis Jacob envoie ses wives et ses enfants
et tout ce qu'il a vaut devant lui.
Across the Jabbok river.
Alors Jacob envoya sa femme, ses serviteurs et tous ses biens en amont devant lui.
Et maintenant il se retrouve seul.
Et c'est en ce moment que Dieu le rencontre.
First at Bethel.
Then at Mahanaim.
Mahanaim.
And finally now God meets with him at Peniel.
And in this place, God meets with him at Peniel.
At Bethel and Mahanaim.
At Bethel.
And in the last place.
God had reassured Jacob of his help.
God reassured Jacob of his help.
But at Peniel, Jacob learned something much deeper.
And it's this meeting that would actually make Jacob fit to re-enter the promised land.
Et c'est cette rencontre qui a rendu Jacob à nouveau légitime de rentrer dans le pays promis.
God's wrestling with Jacob at Peniel is one of the most mysterious incidents,
mysterious stories in all the Bible.
Dieu qui lutte avec Jacob à Peniel est une des histoires les plus mystérieuses de toute la Bible.
What are we to make of this story?
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit ressortir de cette histoire?
It's frightening.
C'est inquiétant.
C'est effrayant.
And yet it's beautiful.
Mais en même temps, c'est beau.
And it's intimate.
Et c'est intime.
It's a transforming encounter with God.
C'est une rencontre qui a transformé Jacob.
It's a sacred place for Jacob.
C'est une place sacrée pour Jacob.
He calls it Peniel.
Il l'a appelé Peniel.
Which in Hebrew means, I've seen the face of God, face to face, and been delivered.
Et ce qui veut dire en Hebrew, j'ai vu la face de Dieu.
J'ai été face à face avec Dieu et j'ai été délivré.
In this story, we find a five-fold contagious blessing that God put upon Jacob.
And my wish for you this morning is that this five-fold contagious blessing may also be granted to you.
Mon souhait, c'est que ces cinq bénédictions contagieuses puissent être vôtres ce matin également.
So my text words are simply the end of verse 29.
Donc nous allons commencer verset 29.
And he, that is God, blessed him, that is Jacob, there.
Et Dieu le bénit là.
La fin du verset 29.
Et il le bénit là.
Il le bénit là.
True blessing.
Une vraie bénédiction.
Contagious blessing.
Une bénédiction contagieuse.
Five-fold blessing.
Une bénédiction qu'on peut diviser en cinq.
Let's look at these blessings.
Et regardons à ces cinq bénédictions.
The first one is contagious perseverance.
La première est une persévérance contagieuse.
You know when this stranger came to wrestle with Jacob.
Vous savez lorsque cet étranger est venu lutter avec Jacob.
It was an overwhelming experience.
C'était une expérience tout à fait bouleversante.
How would you like someone coming to you in the darkness of the night and grabbing hold of you?
Comment penseriez-vous alors que vous êtes dans la nuit à un étranger qui s'approche de vous et qui vous saisit?
A powerful hand of a seemingly merciless assailant laid hold of Jacob.
Une main qui vous assaille.
Une main puissante qui vous assaille.
And Jacob was no pushover.
Et Jacob n'était pas quelqu'un qui se laissait marcher dessus.
He was a strong man.
C'était un homme fort.
Mais il s'est retrouvé coincé dans cette lutte intense.
Verse 24 says,
There wrestled a man with him until the breaking of the day.
Il est dit au verset 24,
Imaginez ces mains suantes d'un homme qui sont sur vous, sur votre corps.
Pressing up himself against you in the midst of the night.
Et qui vous presse et qui vous saisit au milieu même de la nuit.
Jacob is staggering back.
Et Jacob recule.
And he's resisting his opponent's moves.
Et en même temps il repousse les mouvements de son adversaire.
He's using all his energy.
Il utilise toute son énergie.
And he wrestles on and on.
Et il lutte encore et encore.
Jacob.
Persevered.
A persévérer.
Il a lutté jusqu'au lever de l'aurore.
C'est merveilleux.
Si vous savez une chose au sujet de la lutte et du combat.
Vous savez qu'au bout de quelques minutes, deux combattants sont déjà exténués.
Mais alors que Jacob luttait, il a persévéré encore, encore et encore.
Il a commencé à comprendre que ce n'était pas un adversaire habituel.
C'était l'ange de Dieu.
L'ange de l'alliance.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une Christophanie.
C'est Christ dans une forme humaine.
Jacob ne lutte avec personne d'autre que Christ, le Messie.
Le Dieu-homme qui viendra plus tard de la propre semence de Jacob.
Qui mourra pour les péchés de Jacob.
Et qui se lèvera des morts pour sa justification.
Jacob est en train de lutter avec Christ.
Le Messie.
Le saviour.
Le sauveur.
Le judge of the world.
Le juge de ce monde.
Le Messie semble s'attaquer à Jacob.
Et Jacob n'est pas celui qui a commencé la lutte.
C'était pas son idée.
Mais le Messie est arrivé et le Messie a débuté cette lutte.
Sur les bords du pays promis.
Le Dieu-homme commença à lutter avec Jacob.
Et à lutter contre lui.
Est-ce que Dieu a déjà lutté avec vous?
Avez-vous déjà été dans les ténèbres?
Tout seul avec Dieu.
Lutter avec la souffrance, la maladie.
Lutter avec la solitude et les pertes.
Lutter avec des oppositions, des frustrations au beau milieu de la nuit.
Lutter pour ne pas vous soumettre à la volonté de Dieu.
Et la plupart des saints du Seigneur ont lutté contre le découragement.
Et contre les craintes et les doutes.
Contre les tentations.
Contre l'anxiété et les inquiétudes.
Mais principalement contre le péché.
Oh, to wrestle with God in the midnight hours.
Oh, lutter avec Dieu dans les heures ténébreuses.
In the midst of the dark night of the soul.
Et dans les nuits ténébreuses de nos âmes.
Jacob struggled with God.
Jacob a lutté avec Dieu.
Mais son expérience n'est pas inhabituelle.
Jean Calvin le dit de cette manière.
All the servants of God in this world are wrestlers with God.
Tous les saints de ce monde sont des lutteurs avec Dieu.
But what is most experiential in Jacob's life here is the length of this wrestling match.
That he perseveres at it.
This is a blessing.
Mais ce qui est inhabituel dans la lutte de Jacob, c'est la durée de son combat.
La façon dont il a persévéré dans le combat avec Dieu.
Do you know what it is?
Not to give up on the Lord.
Et vous savez ce que c'est de ne pas abandonner avec le Seigneur.
But to say to the Lord.
Mais de dire au Seigneur.
I cannot let you go until thou bless me.
Je ne peux pas te laisser partir avant que tu ne m'aies béni.
Oh, to wrestle with God with holy wrestlings in prayer.
Voici la lutte avec Dieu.
Avec une lutte dans la prière.
That's the first blessing.
C'est la première bénédiction.
It's a blessing when we can't let go of God.
C'est une bénédiction de ne pas vouloir que Dieu s'en aille.
My dad used to always say to me as a boy.
Mon père m'a dit toujours quand j'étais petit.
Two things.
Deux choses.
Never do.
Ne fais jamais.
Never step over your conscience.
Et ne va jamais au-delà de ta conscience.
And never let go of God.
Et ne laisse jamais partir Dieu.
Keep pleading with him until you know him.
Until you're blessed by him.
Continue à plaider Dieu jusqu'à ce que tu le connaisses.
Et ce que tu le rencontres.
The old Scottish divines used to say.
Wrestle with God until you wrestle through.
And gain the victory with the most high.
Et les écossais disaient.
Continue à lutter avec Dieu jusqu'à ce que tu aies un droit d'accès vers celui qui est très haut.
That's what Jacob does here.
Voilà ce que Jacob fait ici.
I will not let thee go.
Until thou bless me.
You know so many people speak about the word blessing so easily today.
You know so many people use the word blessing so easily today.
As pastors we stand at the door of the church.
Many churches.
On se tient à la porte en tant que pastor de nos églises.
And people shake your hand.
And they say I was blessed today.
I was blessed today.
Many of them say that.
And many of them say that.
But what do they mean?
What does it mean to be blessed by God?
To be blessed by God is to have an encounter with God.
And to wrestle with God.
And to persevere with God.
Contagious perseverance.
Une persevere contagieuse.
Oh God help me to persevere with thee who does persevere with me.
Oh Dieu aide moi à persevere envers toi.
Toi qui as persevere envers moi.
But the second contagious blessing here is
Contagious prayer.
C'est une prière contagieuse.
Real wrestling with God is prayerful wrestling with God.
Une vraie bénédiction, une vraie persévérance contagieuse.
C'est une persévérance dans la prière.
There's a Scottish writer by the name of Alexander White.
Il y a Alexander White, un écossais.
He says prayer is colossal work.
It takes all our heart.
All our soul.
All our strength.
All our mind.
And all our life.
I will not let thee go except thou bless me.
And I will not let thee go except thou bless me.
These words of Jacob are not arrogant.
And the words of Jacob are not arrogant.
They're spoken by an exhausted, helpless, broken man.
Ils sont émis par un homme qui est exténué et fatigué.
Who can't let go of God.
Qui ne peut juste pas laisser Dieu partir.
And so he has to pray on.
Alors il doit continuer à prier.
You see, this is one of the greatest blessings
when God brings us into strife.
And God brings us into solitude.
C'est une des plus grandes bénédictions
quand le Seigneur nous met au milieu de la lutte
et au milieu de la solitude.
Think about your own life for a moment.
Pensez à votre propre vie pendant un instant.
When have you been visited by God through his word?
Most often.
Le plus souvent.
When you're all alone.
Lorsque vous êtes seul.
And when you're in strife.
Et lorsque vous êtes dans la difficulté.
When you're in the midst of affliction.
Lorsque vous êtes au milieu des afflictions.
When you're in struggle.
Lorsque vous êtes en pleine lutte.
And you're all alone.
Et que vous êtes tout seul.
And you see, those are exactly the two things
that modern man fights against.
You and I are both alike.
We don't want trouble.
We don't want afflictions.
And we don't want to be alone.
Today you get on an airplane.
And you go to evangelize the man next to you.
And suddenly you realize, oh he's got things in his ears.
He's listening to something.
People today can hardly be alone.
But it's good to be alone.
And to be quiet with God.
And to pour out our every need to him in prayer.
Genuine prayer.
Prayer that goes above the ceiling.
And penetrates the heavens.
And gets the ear of God.
That is a contagious blessing.
You know, when I had the privilege of studying
for my doctorate degree.
When I started.
In the reformers and the puritans.
Excusez-moi.
In the center of the study.
For studying.
And what surprised me.
was that their sermons.
For studying.
In the good.
So I wrestled.
With this question.
I struggled.
Why.
What did they have.
That.
Brought so much.
Blessing of God.
Down upon their churches.
So much.
Genuine.
Reformation.
Revival.
What are we missing today?
What is the difference.
Between the revival.
And what we can live.
Today.
And gradually.
It dawned on me.
I finally understood.
They were men.
Of prayer.
They were wrestlers.
With God.
It was men.
We just let God.
Alone.
So easily.
And sometimes.
We let God.
God.
We don't take the kingdom.
Of heaven.
By violence.
And the violence.
Take it by force.
We don't search.
The kingdom of heaven.
Of heaven.
With violence.
Like we should do.
The Lord says.
In Jeremiah.
Command me.
Concerning the works.
Of my hands.
Command me.
Tell me what to do.
Dans Jérémie.
Command me.
Dis-moi que faire.
Today.
We don't even understand that.
Et parfois.
Nous ne comprenons même pas.
Ses propres mots.
But Martin Luther did.
Mais Martin Luther.
Le pensait vraiment.
You know.
Luther spent.
Two hours.
Every day in prayer.
Vous savez que Martin Luther.
Passait deux heures.
De prière par jour.
And one day.
He had a.
He had a very busy day.
And one day.
He had a really.
Very charged.
He said to his right hand man.
Philip Melanchthon.
And he said to Philip Melanchthon.
Philip I've got so much.
To do today.
I need to spend.
An extra hour.
In prayer.
Philip.
J'ai tellement de choses.
A faire aujourd'hui.
Que j'ai besoin.
De passer une heure.
Supplementaire.
Dans la prière.
Now what happens.
To you and me.
When we have a lot to do.
Qu'est-ce qui nous arrive.
A nous.
Lorsqu'on a beaucoup.
De choses à faire.
Our prayer time shrinks.
Notre prière.
On tendance.
A se réunir.
Because prayer.
Is just an appendix.
To our lives.
Parce que la prière.
N'est simplement.
Qu'une annexe.
A nos vies.
But to Jacob here.
And to the reformers.
And to the Puritans.
Prayer was their life.
Mais pour les Puritans.
Et pour Martin Luther.
La prière.
C'était leur vie.
It was the heart of their life.
C'était le coeur de leur vie.
They could say.
With John Bunyan.
You can do more than pray.
After you have prayed.
But you can't do more than pray.
Until you have prayed.
Sorry.
You can do more than pray.
After you have prayed.
Until you pray.
But you can do more than pray.
You can do more than pray.
So prayer is foundational.
You need to pray your way through the day.
And you have to pray your way through the day.
When I first became a minister.
The very first week.
La première semaine.
A minister who had been a minister for 50 years came to visit me.
And I asked him.
Tell me.
Give me all your wisdom.
What can you tell me about being a young minister?
What advice do you have?
And I said.
As a minister.
Give me some advice.
What can I do as a minister?
He said something to me I never forgot.
And he said something to me that I never forgot.
I have only one thing to tell you.
He said.
If you get this right.
Everything else will fall into place.
And if you understand these things.
Everything will fall into place.
Never.
Undertake even the smallest duty in the ministry.
Without first bowing your knees.
And wrestling with God for his blessing.
If you will be a praying man.
Everything else will fall into place.
If you are a prayer man.
Then everything else will fall into place.
Now I'm not saying you need to pray two or three hours.
There's no legalism here.
I'm not saying you need to pray two or three hours.
But what I am saying is.
You can't have a wonderful close relationship with God.
When you spend two minutes a day in prayer with him.
But what I'm saying is.
You can't have a relationship with God.
You can't say I've got a wonderful relationship with my wife.
And by the way I spend two minutes a day with her.
You can't have a relationship with God.
You can't have a wonderful relationship with God.
Relationships take time.
Relationships involve intimacy.
Relationships involve two-way communication.
Les relations impliquent une interaction dans les deux sens.
God speaking to me through his words.
Je me parle au travers de sa parole.
Me speaking back to God through prayer.
Et moi qui lui parle en retour au travers de la prière.
Crying out to the Lord of hosts.
En criant au Seigneur des seigneurs.
Oh what a contagious blessing prayer is.
Voici la bénédiction contagieuse de la prière.
When I was nine years old my dad.
My dad sat down beside me one day.
Lorsque j'étais jeune mon père m'a dit.
And he took out his wallet.
Il a pris son portefeuille.
And he took out all the money he had.
And he laid it beside me.
Et il a pris toute la monnaie de son portefeuille.
Et il l'a déposé devant moi.
And he said you know what is more valuable than all the money in the world.
Et il m'a dit tu sais ce qui a plus de valeur que tout l'argent du monde.
An open throne of grace.
Un throne ouvert de grâce.
It's worth more than the whole world.
That 24-7.
365.
We can go to God at any moment.
And get the ear of the Lord of Sabaeah.
Cela a bien plus valeur que tout l'argent du monde.
D'avoir un throne ouvert.
7 jours sur 7.
360 jours par an.
Et un Dieu accessible.
Qui a une oreille.
Jacob a reçu non seulement la bénédiction de la persévérance.
Mais aussi la bénédiction de la prière.
Et troisièmement.
Il a eu une bénédiction de pénitence.
De repentance.
You say but where do you see repentance in this story?
Well two places.
One is the angel's crippling touch.
L'un c'est lorsque vous voyez l'ange qui rend Jacob boiteux d'un toucher.
The angel touched Jacob in the hollow of his thigh.
L'ange a touché Jacob au creux de sa cuisse.
His hip was wrenched out of its socket.
Et sa hanche a été disloquée de ses articulations.
Et si vous ignorez la lutte.
Et bien sachez ceci.
Que lorsque vous essayez de déplacer votre adversaire.
Vous utilisez principalement votre hanche.
But notice that the angel did not crush Jacob's hip.
Mais vous voyez que Jacob n'a pas brisé la hanche de Jacob.
He used just enough power to break Jacob's pride and self-reliance.
Il a simplement disloqué sa hanche pour que l'orgueil de Jacob puisse être anéanti.
To bring him down to his knees.
Pour le mettre et le fléchir à genoux.
To remind him of his weakness.
Pour le rappeler de sa faiblesse.
To show him his radical dependence on God.
Pour lui rappeler sa dépendance radicale à son Seigneur.
Jacob was in the grip of God's relentless crippling grace.
Jacob était alors accroché à sa dépendance totale de la grâce de son ange.
And Jacob knew right then he was a beaten man.
Et à ce moment Jacob alors compris qu'il était un homme battu.
He knew right then that God would get the glory.
Il a compris alors que c'est Dieu qui allait recevoir la gloire.
And God would get the victory over him.
Et que Dieu allait avoir la victoire sur lui.
He was wounded.
Il était blessé.
He was bruised.
And what does a wounded bruised wrestler do?
Et qu'est-ce qu'un combattant affaibli est battu fait?
Well there's nothing he can do but just throw his dead weight upon the one wrestling with him.
Il n'y a rien d'autre à faire que se jeter de tout son poids sur l'autre adversaire.
And you see the beauty of this.
Et voyez la beauté de cette chose.
Is that Jacob wins when he surrenders.
Que Jacob gagne alors qu'il...
Il se rend.
Il s'abandonne.
This wrestling match is actually a double win.
It's a win-win on both sides.
En fait, cette issue de combat, c'est gagnant-gagnant.
Jacob wins by losing.
Jacob a gagné en abandonnant.
And God wins.
Et Dieu gagne.
Jacob has his power broken through weakness.
Jacob a sa puissance écrasée dans sa faiblesse.
And prevails.
Et il gagne.
His name is changed to Israel because he prevails with God.
Et son nom a changé de Jacob à Israël parce qu'il a gagné.
God's strength is made perfect in Jacob's weakness.
La force de Dieu s'est manifestée dans la faiblesse de Jacob.
So this wrestling match didn't end in a tie.
Donc cette...
Didn't end in a tie.
Oh it didn't.
Okay.
Donc la fin de son combat n'a pas été une égalité.
It's a double win.
C'est une double victoire.
You see, when we wrestle with God.
Vous voyez, lorsque vous luttez avec Dieu.
And God increases.
Et alors Dieu augmente.
And we decrease.
Et lorsque nous diminuons.
Like John the Baptist said.
Comme Jean-Baptiste le dit.
It's a double win.
C'est une double victoire.
This is the way of holiness.
C'est la façon de la sanctification.
This is the way of repentance.
C'est le chemin de la repentance.
Jacob wins by being blessed.
Jacob gagne en étant béni.
And God wins by blessing.
Et Dieu gagne en bénissant.
And by being the blesser.
Et en étant celui qui bénit.
And being the blessing in the Lord Jesus.
Et en étant la bénédiction dans la personne de Christ.
And getting glory to himself.
Et en se redonnant la gloire à lui-même.
Do you understand that experientially in your own life?
When I am weak.
Then am I strong.
Do you understand that experimentally?
When you are weak.
It's there that you are strong.
You are never stronger.
Than when you are repenting before God.
Martin Luther rightly said.
God would have his people live.
Lifelong repentance.
Martin Luther said.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
You are blessed.
When you are repenting before God.
Every single day.
Every day we sin.
Car chaque jour.
Every day we need repentance.
In the way of sanctification.
C'est le chemin de la sanctification.
In the way of justification.
If you are an assured believer.
You know you will have eternal life.
But you never minimize sin.
And every day you want to clean slate before God.
Every day you want to be washed of those fresh sins.
You want to be washed of those fresh sins.
Just like every day.
You take a shower to cleanse your body.
Like every day you want to be washed of your sins.
To have your body.
So every day you repent of your sins.
To be showered with the grace of God.
So Jacob repents.
Jacob s'est repentant.
But there is a second indication of penitence here.
But there is a second indication of repentance here.
And that is Jacob's new name.
And what do I mean by that?
What do I mean by that?
Well the angel says to Jacob.
What is thy name?
L'ange dit à Jacob.
Quel est ton nom?
You say.
Well if that's Christ.
Of course he knew his name.
Why does he ask him that?
You can say.
If it's Christ.
Evidemment qu'il connaît mon nom.
Pourquoi il me le demande?
Well go back with me 20 years.
Revenez avec moi.
J'entends en arrière.
Do you remember?
20 years before.
He's standing.
In Isaac's bedroom.
Et vous vous souvenez.
20 ans auparavant.
Jacob se tenait au chevet d'Isaac.
Isaac says.
What is your name?
Et Isaac lui demanda.
Quel est ton nom?
Isaac is blind.
Isaac était alors aveugle.
Jacob says.
Esau.
Jacob a alors dit.
Esaü.
Which is a positive name.
Qui est le nom de son frère.
Il n'a pas dit Jacob.
Jacob à ce moment là.
You see.
Il n'a pas dit.
I am Jacob.
The supplanter.
The twister.
The deceiver.
Il n'a pas dit.
Je suis Jacob.
Le trompeur.
Celui qui manipule.
The self-righteous.
The self-ambitious man.
Il n'a pas dit.
Je suis Jacob.
Celui qui se confie dans sa propre justice.
That's who I am.
Car c'est ce que je suis.
Il n'a pas dit cela.
This is the first time.
That Jacob.
Admits.
He's Jacob.
C'est la première fois.
que Jacob admet être Jacob.
What is thy name?
The angel says.
Quel est ton nom?
L'ange lui demande.
Deceiver.
He says.
Le trompeur.
Il répond.
I'm Jacob.
Je suis Jacob.
He becomes what he is before God.
Il devient.
Il dit qu'il est être devant Dieu.
That's what we call repentance.
C'est ça la vraie repentance.
When you become what you are before God.
Lorsque vous êtes celui que vous êtes réellement devant Dieu.
When you take ownership of your own transgressions.
Lorsque vous prenez possession de toutes vos transgressions.
And you repent.
And you say I'm just Jacob.
I'm just a deceiver.
And you repent.
God knows everything about you anyway.
In Psalm 32.
When did David get peace?
When he owned his own transgressions.
He found peace with God.
You can't find peace with God.
When there's unconfessed sin in your life.
Isaiah 59 says.
Your iniquities have separated you from God.
But when you confess them.
When you surrender to God.
When you abandon to God.
Say Lord I deserve to perish.
I deserve to go to hell.
I'm a sinner.
But have mercy upon me.
I can't let you go until you bless me.
That is contagious repentance.
Then fourthly there's contagious power.
Contagious power.
There's contagious power.
Look at verse 28.
Thy name shall no more be called Jacob but Israel.
For as a prince has thou power with God and with men and has prevailed.
Ton nom ne sera plus Jacob but you will be called Israel.
Car tu as lutté avec Dieu et avec des hommes et tu as été vainqueur.
Hosea 12 verse 4.
Hosea au chapitre 12 verse 4.
It says Jacob had power over the angel and prevailed.
He lutta avec l'ange et il fut vainqueur.
By weeping and making supplication over him.
He pleura et lui adressa des supplications.
Isn't that beautiful?
In all our struggles.
We must ultimately deal with God.
Jacob was first worried about Esau coming.
You know Jacob was first worried about Esau coming.
You know Jacob had peur d'Esaü who was on his way.
And about Laban coming.
And of Laban coming.
Would he survive?
But then God comes.
And Esau and Laban fall away.
And Esau and Laban se sont retirés.
And he has to do with God.
And ensuite he has to do with God.
And then he has to do with God.
Calvin writes.
Whenever we are tried and afflicted.
Our business is truly with God.
Peu importe quand nous sommes tentés ou éprouvés.
And God doesn't force himself upon us.
The angel of the Lord could have annihilated Jacob at any moment.
La réalité c'est que l'ange aurait pu détruire Jacob à n'importe quel moment.
But he doesn't annihilate his people.
Mais Dieu ne détruit pas son peuple.
He wants Jacob to come to an end of himself.
Il veut que Jacob arrive à la fin de lui-même.
He wants to break Jacob so that Jacob casts himself entirely on the mercy of God.
Il veut briser Jacob pour que Jacob puisse dépendre totalement de la miséricorde de Dieu.
So he touches his thigh.
And he allows Jacob to prevail.
Et il permet que Jacob ait la victoire dans toute sa faiblesse.
I go back to Calvin again.
This wonderful statement.
Je reviens à Calvin à nouveau.
While God lightly.
Notice the word lightly.
Lightly opposes us.
He at the same time supplies invincible strength.
Whereby we overcome.
Hallelujah.
While God lightly opposes us.
He supplies invincible strength.
Whereby we overcome.
Alors que Dieu de façon légère s'oppose à nous.
En même temps il pourvoit à une grâce extraordinaire pour que nous puissions survivre.
When are we the strongest in our Christian life?
When we've been broken and restored.
Lorsque nous sommes prisés devant le Seigneur.
And then we can minister to others.
And then we can evangelize others.
Ensuite on peut evangeliser auprès d'autres.
Then we can say to others.
If God can save me.
He can save any one of you.
And then we can say to others.
Si Dieu m'a sauvé moi.
Il peut te sauver toi également.
Thy name shall no more be deceiver.
And my name shall be Israel.
Thy name shall be Israel.
My name shall be Israel.
Which means strength and power with God and with man.
God's power will prevail in his children so that they will prevail with God.
La force de Dieu va prévaloir dans le coeur des hommes.
Afin que l'homme puisse prévaloir avec Dieu.
So yes we suffer.
We struggle.
We wrestle with God.
Donc oui nous luttons avec Dieu.
But when we are finally broken and we cling to him.
Mais lorsque nous sommes finalement brisés et que nous nous attachons à lui.
We become Israel.
Alors nous devenons princes with God.
Des princes avec Dieu.
Well what a beautiful thing this is.
Quelle chose merveilleuse n'est-ce pas?
As Jacob leaves Peniel.
Alors que Jacob quitte Peniel.
Verse 31 says.
The sun rose upon him.
Le verset 31 nous dit.
Le soleil se levait.
You can't always stay at a place where you have an intimate encounter with God.
You can't.
You can't always stay there.
You can't always stay in these moments of bénédiction particulière in the presence of Dieu.
Your life must move on.
Votre vie doit reprendre son cours.
Jacob had to leave Peniel.
Et Jacob a dû quitter Peniel.
But he doesn't leave as he came.
Mais il n'a pas quitté comme il est arrivé.
He came as Jacob.
Il est venu comme Jacob.
He leaves as Israel.
Et il quitte cet endroit comme étant Israel.
And the sun rises upon him.
Et maintenant le soleil se lève.
Beautiful symbolism.
Quel symbole merveilleux.
A sunrise suggests promise.
Le soleil qui se lève suggère des promesses.
The promise.
The beauty of a new day.
La beauté d'un nouveau jour.
It suggests peace.
A sunrise is very peaceful.
Ça suggère la paix.
Un lever de soleil est apaisant.
And it suggests purity.
A sunrise just seems like the sun reaches down into the valleys.
And sweeps everything clean.
Et ça suggère aussi la pureté.
Les rayons de soleil vont dans le creux des vallées.
Pour tout nettoyer.
Pour tout illuminer.
So there goes Jacob.
Halting on his thigh.
Et Jacob boiteux maintenant au soleil.
Broken in himself.
Brisé en lui-même.
Prevailing with God.
Mais vainqueur avec Dieu.
Il va avec une promesse du Fils de justice.
Avec la paix puissante.
The powerful purity.
The powerful purity of the son of righteousness.
Powerful purity.
Avec la pureté puissante qu'il a reçue.
He finds everything in the angel of the covenant with whom he wrestled.
Il provoie toutes ces choses-là dans l'ange avec qui il a lutté.
Oh contagious power.
Et puissance contagieuse.
Et finalement un prix contagieux.
Il est toujours en douleur.
Il est halting upon his thigh.
Verse 31 says.
Le verset 31 nous dit.
Il boitait de la hanche.
God puts a permanent mark on Jacob.
Dieu a mis une marque permanente dans le corps de Jacob.
He's never the same again.
Il n'est plus à jamais le même.
This is what the Puritans used to call severe mercy.
Voilà ce que les Puritans ont appelé des miséricordes sévères.
God grants us sometimes what we think we cannot bear.
And takes from us what we think we cannot miss.
Dieu parfois nous accorde des choses que nous pensons ne pas supporter.
Et nous enlève des choses que nous pensons ne pas pouvoir abandonner.
But these severe mercies just drive us closer to God.
Mais ces miséricordes sévères ne font que nous rapprocher de Dieu.
And make us more like Christ.
Et elles nous font plus ressembler à Dieu.
Even the world is watching the Christian when the Christian is afflicted.
Même le monde regarde comment les chrétiens réagissent lorsqu'ils sont frappés par les afflictions.
And if you are drawn closer to Christ in affliction.
Et alors que vous êtes attiré près de Dieu dans vos afflictions.
Even though you are halting on your thigh.
Même si vous vous penchez, boitez avec votre hanche.
Even though you have pain one way or another.
Même si vous avez de la douleur d'une façon ou d'une autre.
But you end up glorifying God.
Et que vous finissez par glorifier Dieu.
You end up being Israel.
Vous finissez en étant Israël.
The world will sit up and notice.
Le monde vous regardera.
Et vous remarquera.
And say, that Christian has something I don't have.
Et il se dira en lui-même, ce chrétien a quelque chose que je n'ai pas.
It's a contagious price.
C'est un prix contagieux.
Thank God for injuring you.
Because if you were never injured, you'd be standing way too tall.
You'd be going through life thinking that you could save yourself.
You could make life ends meet.
You'll be going through life thinking that you, by your own means, you could arrive.
But no.
God puts thorns in our flesh.
So that we may say with Paul.
I take pleasure in infirmities.
In necessities.
In persecution.
In distresses.
In the désespoir.
For Christ's sake.
For when I am weak, then am I strong.
Sometimes we get weary.
Sometimes we're wrestling in the dark.
And we're tired.
And we think the Lord is not going to visit us.
And we think there's no way out of the dilemma in which we are in.
But there is.
God promises in Proverbs.
There shall surely come an end.
And thy affliction also shall end.
Thy expectations shall not be cut off.
God will bring a solution.
Peniel.
I have seen God face to face.
And my life has been preserved.
So I leave Peniel.
Wounded.
But I'm healed.
Hallelujah.
And I'm marching onward.
And I'm not the same as I was.
But I'm still going forth.
But I'm still going forward.
And I'm more useful in God's making me weak than I was in my own strength.
And I'm now much more useless in the weaknesses that God gave me.
I'm making progress.
And I'm making progress.
Even though I often feel I'm a greater sinner than ever.
Even if I think in myself that I'm the greatest sinner than ever.
This is a five-fold contagious blessing.
Voici les cinq bénédictions que nous pouvons recevoir.
I want Jacob's contagious perseverance.
I want Jacob's contagious prayer.
I want Jacob's contagious penitence.
I want Jacob's contagious power.
I want Jacob's contagious price.
Even though I still feel too much like I'm still Jacob.
Even though I'm still Jacob.
And not Israel.
Maybe you're so broken you can't see the way out.
But maybe you're so broken you can't see the way out.
I've got some comfort for you.
But I've got some comfort for you.
It's this.
Twenty times.
After God renamed Jacob.
He says in the Bible.
I am the God of Jacob.
Hallelujah.
I'm the God of deceivers.
And I will remake them.
And I will heal them.
Happy.
Says Psalm 144.
Soyez dans la joie.
Joyeux.
Heureux.
Happy is he that has the God of Jacob for his help.
Heureux celui qui a le Dieu de Jacob comme son aide.
Nous dit le psaume 24.
Yeah.
Happy is that people whose God is the Lord.
Heureux le peuple dont le Seigneur est leur Dieu.
Come just as you are.
Venez comme vous êtes.
To the God of Jacob.
Au Dieu de Jacob.
He will bless you there.
Il vous bénira là.
Amen.